bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous on
vient de voir un lien qui est frappée
très cruellement à cette vague
épidémique hors de contrôle
une donnée qui est important dans ce
pays puisqu'il est peuplé de 1,3
milliard d'habitants mais cela
n'explique pas tout n'est ce pas oui en
effet le prochain recensement fera
probablement apparaître que l'inde est
devenue le pays le plus peuplé du monde
avec probablement plus d'habitants que
que la chine mais l'un d'eux c'est aussi
le pays où coexistent les technologies
et elle est plus des plus aisées plus
sophistiqués la haute technologie avec
la pauvreté absolue
c'est aussi le pays où une
administration tatillonne coexiste avec
des hommes d'affaires extrêmement
innovant c'est d'ailleurs eux qui ont
construit cette capacité de fabriquer
des vaccins qui est la première au monde
sans aucun conteste et bien le système
sanitaire indien il est à l'image de
cette société il y a d'un côté des
hôpitaux privés qui sont assez bien
équipé mais dont les prix sont hors de
portée pour la plupart de la population
des hôpitaux publics qui eux sont mal
équipés parce que les gouvernements
successifs n'ont pas fait les
investissements suffisants à l'exception
peut-être de quelques gouvernements
régionaux comme au kerala et par
conséquent on voit ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pour la production d'oxygène
médical avec une insuffisance des moyens
logistiques pour faire parvenir cet
oxygène de qualité médicale aux hôpitaux
qui en ont besoin
avec eux le manque de camions équipés
des moyens réfrigérant nécessaire le
manque de capacité de stockage et même
le manque de bouteille
donc ces images de familles désespérées
qui vont acheter au prix fort des
bouteilles chez les revendeurs dans les
différentes villes
et bien ce gouvernement qui est au
pouvoir depuis 2000 14 depuis sept ans
est un gouvernement qui se veut un
doubiste par conséquent monsieur moody a
été dans un premier temps l'année
dernière au début de la première vague
de l'épidémie dans le déni parce qu'il
était impensable que le pays au milieu
de milliers de dieu puisse être soumis à
une telle malédiction
et puis voyant ce qui se passait dans
les autres pays dans le monde il a
décrété fin mars l'année dernière un
confinement généralisée très brutale
pendant deux mois mais qui évidemment a
mis l'économie indienne par terre et
donc il s'est juré de ne plus jamais
recommencer
et c'est pour cela qu'aujourd'hui il ne
veut par confiner alors que les experts
considèrent que cette deuxième vague
l'exigerait 1re confinement le dr fauci
le célèbre spécialiste américain dit que
l'inde a besoin d'un confinement absolu
pendant plusieurs semaines mais comment
en est on arrivé là et pourquoi
d'ailleurs cette deuxième vague est bien
parce que ce gouvernement hindouiste
naturellement ne pouvait pas interdire
le plus grand pèlerinage de l'unc a lieu
tous les dix ans à haridwar sur le gange
où pendant plusieurs semaines des
millions de pèlerins sont ensemble
agglutinés et prennent des bains d'eau
dans le fleuve sacré et de la même
manière puisqu'il veut s'assurer du
pouvoir dans les dents les dans les
états qui ne contrôle pas encore eh bien
le même gouvernement a participé à des
meetings à des réunions politiques dans
les différentes dans les différents
états qui avait des élections le mois
dernier et ses grands meetings
évidemment on était aussi des lieux de
contamination alors vous parlez de cette
stratégie du gouvernement et ses choix
il faut préciser que le parti
nationaliste hindou du premier ministre
le bjp a essuyé un revers électoral dans
un état clé qui fait quand même 80
millions d'habitants c'est tout ce que
la france elle même est ce qu'on peut
attribuer cette défaite justement à
cette crise du coronavirus et à sa
gestion surtout vous avez raison c'est
une défaite importante
il n'est pas certain qu'elle soit due à
la mauvaise gestion de la pandémie parce
qu'il se trouve que le
bengale-occidental calcutta par
conséquent ont été atteints par la
deuxième vague plus tard que les autres
états est en réalité calcutta et la
région du bengale occidental en général
ce sont des zones avec une grande
tradition intellectuelle une grande
tradition de discussion une tradition
aussi de tolérance il à vis des
différentes religions et puis plus du
tiers de la population est de confession
musulmane alors que en 1/2 la moyenne
est d'environ 14% et par conséquent la
population du bengale occidental a assez
mal pris la politique d'indemnisation à
outrance que monsieur moody a accéléré
depuis sa réélection triomphale au
printemps 2010 9 avec notamment des lois
qui stigmatise les musulmans
donc il est probable que madame mamata
banerjee qui est le chief minister de
cet état l'un des rares une des rares
femmes chief minister en ahl et qui a
beaucoup de charisme comme d'ailleurs
monsieur maudit et bien a pris le
leadership d'une véritable opposition à
ce pouvoir et que probablement à
l'avenir on reparlera d'elle à la gagner
en effet les deux tiers des sièges à la
législation dans la législature des du
bengale de l'ouest mais on a aussi
observé une défaite du bjp
dans les deux états du sud qui sont très
importants le tamil nadu et le kerala
alors au kerala il ya une tradition qui
est que le parti communiste indien
alternent au pouvoir avec le parti du
congrès fameux party d'indépendance et
bien là le parti communiste qui était au
pouvoir depuis législature a été réélu a
été reconduit
parce que probablement en effet ses
investissements dans les hôpitaux font
que le système sanitaire au kerala était
en meilleur état que ailleurs dans
d'autres états de l'inde est tous au
tamil nadu et bien il ya eu un débat
très important entre deux partis
régionaux et c'est finalement l'un des
deux partis régionaux qui l'a emporté
monsieur moody a eu beau faire de
nombreux meetings son ministre de
l'intérieur à mitch a également les
meetings contaminants puisqu'il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui étaient les uns sur
les autres
eh bien ça n'a plus aucun effet puisque
il n'y a aucun élu bjp à la chambre du
du thé du tamil nadu et que c'est un
certain monsieur monsieur staline qui
n'a rien à voir avec son homonyme
soviétique et qui sera le chief minister
du tamil nadu des kits qui gouverne avec
un parti de centre gauche qui par
conséquent poursuivra la politique du
gouvernement précédent d'un autre parti
régional il ya donc une reconfiguration
de la situation politique en inde une
confirmation que l'inde est un pays
démocratique que le bjp ne peut pas
accueillir tous les pouvoirs et qu' un
certain nombre d'états font de la
résistance et qu'il ya une opposition
n'a alors ce n'est pas nécessairement
celle du parti du congrès ça peut être
aussi celle de partis régionaux et
l'idée régionaux particulièrement fort
alors on ne peut pas évoquer l'un des
clubs blanche maison sans parler du
dispositif kovats il fait évidemment
largement les frais de la crise en inde
qui est il faut le rappeler le premier
fournisseur du programme international
et ce programme est ce qu'il est
clairement en péril aujourd'hui
ce programme il a été initié par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
par les ong gâchis qu'est l' ong pour la
promotion des vaccins qui s'est chargée
elle de recueillir de recueillir les
dons la différence d'un certain nombre
de pays de façon à pouvoir offrir des
vaccins gratuit aux pays qui n'en n'ont
pas les moyens et un milliard a été
promis par monsieur joe biden un
milliard de dollars 850 milliards 650
millions pardon d'euros ce qui revient à
peu près au même montant pour l'union
européenne et puis un certain nombre de
pays à sa tante d'état ont également
promis des sommes donc les premiers
financements sont là insuffisant a bien
entendu monsieur tedros débrayé douce le
directeur général de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
il voudrait 10 milliards de dollars de
façon pour vacciner tout le monde et il
dit à juste raison que tant qu'il y a
des pays infectés par ce virus est bien
le danger il est général parce qu'on ne
peut pas empêcher la circulation
on peut confiner qui l'on veut mais les
gens continueront de circuler et on le
voit bien actuellement avec le variant
indien qui pénètre un peu partout même
sur le territoire français par
conséquent les kovac signer tout le
monde est en effet monsieur narendra
modi a été contraint de décréter à la
fin du mois de mars un embargo sur
l'exportation des vaccins comme les plus
grandes usines de fabrication de vaccins
se trouve en inde
eh bien il en résulte que le système
kovacs des plus suffisamment
approvisionné en vaccins en réalité ces
livraisons sont différées puisque les
pays les plus riches se sont
approvisionnés sur le marché mondial est
bien entendu ont pris ce qui était
disponible sur ce marché par conséquent
le système kovacs s'approvisionnera
ensuite notamment essentiellement en
inde probablement à hauteur de plus de
la moitié est évidemment il va y avoir
un décalage de quelques mois et
probablement bien sûr les premières les
premières
livraisons ont été faites notamment par
la france en afrique de l'ouest
d'autres livraisons été faite dans
quelques pays africains et d'amérique
latine mais l'essentiel sera fait à la
fin de l'année 2021 et en 2022
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales